we know the government watches us but
what about when government surveillance
changes the course of history in the
1960s the US government started a
program called COINTELPRO or the
counterintelligence program the program
was a series of secret FBI initiatives
targeting activists political and
minority groups the American Indian
Movement the Black Panthers Martin
Luther King women's and civil rights
groups Vietnam War protesters and anyone
who got the government seeing red
tactics used included infiltration and
surveying and discrediting leaders and
causes in order to undermine entire
movements and organizations but a lot of
what COINTELPRO did was illegal and it
was officially disbanded in 1971 though
if you ask many activist groups and
political dissidents it still exists
just in another form
you